this was interesting there are some
protesters who crashed a drag queen
story hour event in california over the
weekend now we've seen some of the
footage of protests outside of drag
queen story hour events other drag queen
events where kids are brought there uh
we know what happened in texas with the
the drag event at a gay bar and kids
were brought in by their abusive parents
there were protesters outside people
confronting the drag queens outside
which is good but in this case um the
protesters went all the way into the
building and actually into the event
itself to confront the drag queen and
the parents
and let's hear how that confrontation
went
so who brought the training
who brought the pedophile
[Music]
thank you though
who brought the pedophile
i just want to know
[Music]
yourself you should be ashamed of
yourself
why would you want to bring children to
this why would you want to expose your
children to this just to prove how you
are a pedophile this is the only thing
you want to expose your children to
pedophiles for how tall you are this is
disgusting
really good question they asked there
why would you want to
expose your kids to this
good question love to hear an answer to
that they don't have an answer at least
not an answer they're going to say out
loud why would you want to expose your
kids to this
i mean you want your kids to go to the
library hear a story you want a kid
that's totally understandable
i read stories to my kids all the time
uh we've brought our kids to story times
at libraries they used to be a pretty
uncontroversial thing
why do you need a cross-dressing man to
read the story is the question
why do you need a man who to is acting
out his sexual fetish um
why do you need to incorporate that into
the story time
why
good question answer now the drag queen
there who showed up
cross-dressing for kids to read the
story you know he of course has been in
front of media talking about how
terrified he is now and how what a
terrible thing this was
um how uncomfortable he is now
but here's the thing uh
in in a civilized society and an insane
society
you should be made uncomfortable
when you're going to do this in front of
kids
okay people involved in combining drag
queens and kids if they feel
uncomfortable about that
they feel like what they're doing is a
little bit uh contentious
that that's how they should feel like
you shouldn't feel
like it's a normal comfortable thing
to just combine kids and drag queens
because it's not normal and it's not
okay
and this is at a library by the way
let's let's keep that in mind this is at
a library this is a this is a tax-funded
institution
so other taxpayers have every right
to voice their disapproval
of what their tax money is being used to
do
and even if it isn't a tax-funded
institution this is child abuse
and people have every right to express
their disapproval of child abuse now
um that's what i would say anyway but
law enforcement they're saying something
different in fact they are now
investigating this as a hate crime
what you just saw there is a hate crime
a hate crime against
who drag queens drag queens are now a
protected class of
people
i mean what's what's the uh you know
this isn't even we're gonna try to
charge them with disturbing the peace or
uh
uh anything like that
harassment i mean they might try to
throw some of those charges on there too
i'm sure they will but uh we're not
talking about that part of it okay
hate crime
now even according to the way the hate
crime laws are written and there are a
lot of problems with the way they're
written there are a lot of problems with
just the hate crime category in general
but
the way it's supposed to work is that uh
if you
do something discriminatory or uh
in a harassing manner towards a
protected class of people
and again the fact that there are
protected classes
which means that there are then
unprotected classes the fact that we
have this
is in itself a huge problem
and also unconstitutional i would say
because everybody is guaranteed equality
under the law and when you single out
certain classes as protected and others
other classes as not then that's not
equality under the law but putting that
aside for a second
are drag queens protected classes now
that's like a demographic
a a guy who enjoys cross-dressing is now
that's their that's their own category
of people
have you ever looked at your credit card
statement and been shocked by the
interest rate did you did you know you
could actually roll all of your credit
card debt into one monthly payment at a
lower fixed interest rate you might not
have known that now you do lower your
interest rate and save with a credit
card consolidation loan from light
stream rates start at 5.73 apr with auto
pay and excellent credit plus the rate
is fixed so it will never go up over the
life of the loan you get a loan from 5
dollars to a hundred thousand dollars
and there are absolutely no fees
attached you can even get your money as
soon as the day you apply livestream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver just
for my listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get the
discount is to go to lightstream.com
walsh that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com slash walsh
subject credit approval rates range from
5.73 apr to 19.99 apr include point five
percent auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply and offers are changed
without notice visit lightstream.com
walsh for more information
says uh according yahoo news california
police are investigating after a group
of men allegedly interrupted a drag
queen story hour the library in san
francisco bay area the men who police
believed to be part of the far-right
proud boys reportedly yelled homophobic
and anti-lgbtq plus slurs
now that part the homophobic and
anti-lgbt slurs i didn't hear that in
the video now the video does go on for a
while longer maybe there are other
videos too i don't know i didn't hear in
that clip
um and they don't in in this article
they don't quote what exactly those
slurs were
everything i heard in that clip was
directed at the the drag queen and the
whole concept of combining drag queens
and kids that's their problem
on saturday afternoon police responded
to calls around 1 30 pm that there was a
disturbance at the san lorenzo library
during the story reading
authorities said that a group of five
men had disrupted the event which was
attended by children parents and
community members the men began to shout
homophobic and transphobic slurs at the
event organizer the men were described
as extremely aggressive with a
threatening violent demeanor causing
people to fear for their safety
an active hate crime investigation is
underway
as is an investigation into the annoying
and harassing of children
uh the annoying and harassing of
children
annoying is that actual crime now first
of all
being annoying is a crime
there are a lot of people i know who
need to be arrested in that case
but no they weren't harassing the
children they were asking anybody it was
the adults that's what all this is
directed at
they were there because their belief is
that the children are being harassed by
the event
and they're correct in that
belief by the way the police added as we
celebrate pride month we will be swift
in our response to any incidents where
there are threats to harm members of
this community of what community the
drag queen community
or are you saying that uh dressing in
drag in front of children
is what
synonymous
with the gay community in general
i think there are plenty of gay people
that disagree with that
you know i'm pretty sure there are
plenty of gay people who would say that
uh uh
no
you can you can be a po just because
you're opposed to
um drag queen story hour
like that has nothing to do with me
this to me seems um very it's it's sort
of a similar thing to when uh when
people just like that what's going on
with jack del rio
who criticized blm rioting and then is
accused of being racist
by people who i guess are
saying are insinuating
that violent rioting is an essential
part of black culture
that's what they're saying and that if
you oppose violent writing then you're
opposing black people
so the law enforcement here i guess
they're saying the same thing kind of
about the gay community they're saying
that uh dressing in dragon from the
children is an essential part of gay
culture and therefore if you oppose that
then you oppose gay people that's what
they are saying
they're either saying that or they're
saying that um
that drag queens themselves are their
own protected class protected community
whatever however you explain it it's
totally
insane absolute nonsense
um
the host drag queen panda dulce told
local public radio station
kqed that when the men came in shouting
uh
okay they're using the female pronouns
oh my gosh
that when the men came in shouting at
her
she was eventually escorted out of the
room by a security guard for her safety
that's the other thing i've actually
noticed this recently when when the
media talks about drag queens
they use the female pronoun
but the whole point of a drag queen is
that it's a man dressing as a woman
that's what a drag queen is by
definition
so now they are connecting drag queens
and transgenderism
but a drag queen by if if it's a if it's
a woman
dressed like that then it's not drag
that's just a woman
so what i guess in the media in the
article they are just sort of referring
to her
to referring to him as the character
that he's playing which is a female
uh
dolce whose name is kyle casey chu says
i didn't know if they were armed i was
only acutely aware of the fact that
neither myself nor any of the other
librarians were armed
they totally freaked out the kids they
got right in our faces they jeered they
attempted to escalate to violence
i didn't see any of that did you i
didn't see in anyone's face i didn't see
an attempt to escalate the violence
[Music]
and i didn't see them attacking the kids
in any way whatsoever
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated